Qué opina usted sobre las palabras
como dices tú una serie de
de
argumentos no no ciertos Eh vale
falsedades que le muestra sin embargo la
repite con mucha certidumbre con mucha
confianza y algunos seguidores le le
creerán como decía Google Una mentira
dicha mil veces se convierte en verdad Y
es a lo que le está apostando Donald
Trump sin embargo muchas falsedades aquí
un ejemplo de ello Es que no niega haber
tomado los documentos importante no hay
mucha evidencia no puede negar que no se
ha llevado de documentos secretos lo
segundo es que él dice que esto está
bajo el acto de registros presidenciales
sin embargo si uno Lee ese acto uno ve
que este acto también dice que los
documentos presidenciales y de gobierno
no son propiedad privada del presidente
sino que son propiedad pública de la
nación y que le pertenecen los archivos
nacionales los archivos de la nación
para que puedan en el futuro ser usados
por historiadores por periodistas y
demás entonces también esta esta defensa
de que es el el acta de registro
presidenciales eh No le ayuda en nada
porque indica lo mismo entonces este
una serie de de falsedades que él repite
y que no le van a quitar estos problemas
que le imputan con muchas evidencias en
contra suya en el caso Pero bueno ya
dirá Cuál es la opinión del juzgado y y
la juez tendrá mucho Aquí que que
influir en Cómo se lleve a cabo el
juicio Y cuándo
logremos así se tarde meses como lo
hemos dicho en tener un veredicto final
en este caso Ernesto Castañeda analista
político profesora asociado del
departamento de sociología del American
University Gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en France 24
gracias buenas